si reed padovan et français il est
gérant d'une chaîne de centres
esthétiques et salons de coiffure à
barcelone fermées pendant cette semaine
ses centres rouvrent petit à petit après
avoir mis en place de strictes mesures
d'hygiène ils doivent se laver les mains
au savon dès qu'il arrive nous donner
leurs affaires donc tout même le mobile
alors ça c'est le plus compliqué parce
qu'avant elle avait le mobile tout le
temps est là mais n'a pas pu l'utiliser
et ensuite on leur donne du gel
hydroalcoolique donc tout ça on vérifie
maintenant que toutes les étapes soit
fait avant de faire le soir pour les
employés les mesures sont avant tout
rassurante
les espaces sont désinfectés entre
chaque client masques et gants sont
portés en permanence pour les manucures
les épilations et tout autre traitement
nous sommes bien équipés car cela nous
protège bien les yeux le nez et la
bouche et ça nous empêche de nous
toucher le visage quand on est avec la
cliente
les clients ont répondu présent et pris
rendez vous dès le premier jour
d'ouverture pour bénéficier des soins
mais pas sans garanties d'hygiène
ils ont un système de rendez vous et
nous nous sommes mis d'accord via
internet et ils m'ont tout de suite
trouvé un rendez-vous adapté à mes
nécessité cela a été très rapide et très
facile moi je suis très attentive aux
mesures qui sont prises mais une fois
qu'on arrive ici c'est très clair ils
ont un protocole bien organisés et je me
suis senti très en sécurité dès que j'ai
passé la porte
le centre ouvrira sa partie salon de
coiffure dès la semaine prochaine mais
craint déjà pour les prochains mois
situé en plein centre de barcelone
il ne pourra pas cette année compter sur
les nombreux visiteurs étrangers de la
capitale catalane
la ville se prépare déjà un été sans
touristes